[Music]
chelsea's with us in reno nevada hi
chelsea welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um so sorry i'm a little nervous um my
husband and i are on baby steps four
five and six and we make pretty decent
money and have a christmas seeking fund
but always feel guilty
every year like we never have enough
saved after cash flowing life and we end
up going
over budget every year some of our
family is very wealthy and has
everything and are always super generous
to us and others are normal and deserve
nice things so what's a healthy budget
for christmas
yours isn't
because it's not working right
right so like how do i determine you
know how much i should be allocating to
each person
like gifts are my love language and a
lot of my family's love language
always been a big deal but it's just
like every year we
just never seem to have enough and it
doesn't make sense
yeah let me ask you this when you say
gifts are your love language
chelsea because i i i understand that i
love giving gifts i love receiving gifts
to you does the monetary value of the
gift correlate with how much you love a
person
or is it how much thought is put into it
or no it's really the thought but i do
like to give
things that they normally wouldn't by
themselves like to me that's exciting to
see them
be excited about something nice yeah
that lasts about 45 seconds and the pain
lasts till may
so um we're not really going over out of
like we're not going into dead over it
it's just kind of
what how should we be planning you know
better throughout the year because we
seem to set a dollar amount but
it goes out the window in a way or
doesn't the reason it's going out the
window is not the dollar amount the
reason it's going out the window is you
don't know how to say no
yeah that's what to say the dollar
amount is really not the question here
it's how to make you all behave
in relation to the dollar amount so
whatever the dollar amount you sit what
set that you're okay with you just have
to actually stick
to it it's a very different thing
between knowing something and doing it
and you guys just have to do it
and to your point chelsea even if you
want to come in under budget or make
people you know
the love language of gifts i get that
but you can do that in a very thoughtful
way and stick to your budget or even
spend less than you are
and accomplish your goal of of making
your family feel loved at christmas
but you have to stick to it christmas is
not going to
make or break a relationship if it does
it wasn't a real relationship
christmas gift giving is not going to
you're not going to give
your family which is not wealthy or his
family which is wealthy
enough to change their lives
and so this is just a it's a it's a
gesture
it's a gesture and i think you're
putting too much pressure on yourself
and you're putting actually too much
importance on it
um and uh you know i'm not against
giving gifts i believe in giving gifts
i'm not
the grinch but you you're telling us
that this is creating emotional havoc
for you
uh you know you feel like like you have
a financial hangover
after christmas is over because you feel
like you regret your behavior
you've got you've shamed yourself over
it and so
um you know really the um there's not a
there's not a magic amount
that says this is the proper amount for
christmas the average family last year
spent about 900
just to give you an idea it's the
average family budget for christmas
and that's on an average household
income of about 60 000
so but you know we don't make average at
the ramsey house and we spend a lot more
than that on christmas
but we don't have any weird regrets from
it we have a budget and that's
that's what we're going to spend and
that's all we do and so just give
yourself a guideline
that you both feel good about while
you're calm
and then just be grown up and stick to
it when christmas gets here so you don't
have these feelings but there's not
anything you're going to medicate with
this that's going to make it okay
this is the dave ramsey show